When it comes to anomalous religions, the
SCP Foundation is no stranger to them.
The weird, wild, and utterly incomprehensible
belief systems that populate the world of
the anomalous might seem too crazy and dangerous
to participate in on paper, but if there’s
anything that brings people together, it’s
the power of faith and belief.
Take for example the Mekhanites, a massive
religious following with various sects located
across the globe, united in their belief that
body-modification using technology is the
pathway to worship their god, Mekhane, the
Broken God who will one day reassemble the
lost parts of its body and usher the universe
into a new age of technological superiority.
Or the cult-like Children of the Scarlet King,
who worship a brutal ancient entity known
as the Scarlet King, who exists as a dangerous
idea, unable to be accurately described or
cataloged by contemporary science, separating
the ages of modernity and antiquity, and invigorating
its followers to commit horrible acts in the
name of their King.
But if you’re a long time viewer of SCP
Explained, then chances are you’ve heard
of the Broken God and the Scarlet King, arguably
two of the most popular anomalous religions.
So today, we’re going to be talking about
one you might not have heard about – Fifthism.
Fifthism is a lot more difficult to explain,
because instead of a central prevailing deity
and strict belief system that unites Fifthists,
the religion is defined more by its nonsensical,
illogical, and absurd state of mind that it
imposes on its followers.
Fifthism is all consuming, a mindset that
is often transmitted through memetic means,
such as books that contain rambling paragraphs
of surreal imagery and platitudes that are
dispersed among unsuspecting populations by
Fifthists.
Those who read Fifthist literature often succumb
to Fifthist beliefs themselves, losing their
mind and delving into a strange world centered
around cosmic starfish and the number five,
where nothing makes sense, but it doesn’t
matter, because you’ve now been enlightened,
and to the Fifthist zealot, it all makes sense.
The Foundation had to deal with a dangerous
piece of Fifthist literature in the past.
SCP-1425, the book titled Star Signals, was
a self-help book with memetic properties that
nearly consumed the mind’s of the entire
world, becoming a national best-seller, that
forced the Foundation to take extreme measures
to purge it from public knowledge and destroy
every remaining copy.
Just listen to this excerpt from SCP-1425,
which illustrates the strange, mind-altering
Fifthist doctrine.
“Now imagine that the place where your desires
are made real has a name.
It’s called the Fifth World.
The Fifth World is the cosmos twisted around
you into the shape you will wish for.
It has never been, but you can make it so.
If the current world is like a tight, collared
suit, then the Fifth World is like a flowing
robe that allows complete freedom of movement.
You will never truly move before you move
in the Fifth World.
You’ll feel like a square on a piece of
paper who was only just made about up and
down.”
When dealing with Fifthism, that’s the kind
of strangeness you’re guaranteed to encounter.
The Foundation’s operation to get SCP-1425
under control took weeks, and didn’t work
out as smoothly as they hoped, proving the
religion as a force to be reckoned with, and
definitely not one to take lightly.
But the story of Star Signals, SCP-1425, is
one for another day.
Now that you have a crash course in Fifthism,
we can get to the real reason you’re here:
SCP-2456 Dreams of a Broken World.
What exactly is SCP-2456?
Well, if you guessed that it’s Fifthist,
you would be correct, but considering what
we know about Fifthism, that could mean anything!
SCP-2456’s discovery dates back to a Foundation
operation in Eugene Orgeon, where Foundation
operatives raided the hideout of individuals
belonging to the Serpent’s Hand, a para-military
resistance organization unified by their belief
that the world should embrace the anomalous.
The Serpent’s Hand has been heavily critical
of groups like the Global Occult Coalition
and SCP Foundation, their containment, and
especially their destruction of anomalous
objects and entities.
In an ideal world for a member of the Hand,
anomalies co-exist with the world we know.
It’s an idealistic picture, but their antagonism
against the Foundation has painted a serious
target on their back, subjecting them to frequent
ambushes and raids on their hideouts.
And that’s exactly what happened inside
the abandoned warehouse where SCP-2456 was
discovered.
The Foundation sent a highly trained Mobile
Task Force, a squad named Bookworms, after
one of the remaining copies of SCP-1425, the
Fifthist self-help book Star Signals, which
was supposedly stowed away inside the warehouse.
Upon entry, the operatives stumbled upon a
Serpent’s Hand hideout, and a firefight
between Hand members and Foundation operatives
ensued.
The Task Force suffered minor casualties,
but they managed to secure a hold over the
warehouse after a brief struggle.
Inside, they not only found the copy of Star
Signals, but several other anomalous artifacts
that the Hand was using to further its goals.
During the inventory, another curious object
was found, a wooden crate with a label that
read ‘FIFTH CYCLE OF THE MIND’ stamped
onto its side.
When opened, the Foundation uncovered dozens
more copies of Star Signals, as well as numerous
other Fifthist texts, and a weathered note
signed by an unknown individual that read:
“George, this is our latest catch; please
burn these as soon as you can at your discretion.
Don't let the idiots find this.”
At the very bottom of the crate, several manuscripts
were discovered that contained information
about a then-unknown Fifthist anomaly involving
a strange variation of the belief system,
which the Foundation immediately began researching.
The manuscripts pointed towards the existence
of an abstract theology that has existed for
centuries, that, when preached by its believers,
transmits a memetic virus.
This religion is varying in characteristics,
but is distinguishable by several qualities,
such as starting out as a variation of an
existing theology, making frequent use of
the number five in its written doctrine, and
revolving around godhead figures that are
synonymous with the sun, who are believed
to bring about a future apocalypse.
On top of those, written works make mention
of a nonexistent sea, frequent references
to celestial objects, the appearance of hands
as a religious symbol, and the belief that
the sun has great mathematical significance
and importance.
If all of that sounds confusing to you, congratulations,
you’re immune to Fifthism.
If it sounds appealing, well, you might just
be affected by SCP-2456.
SCP-2456 is a memetic parasite, transmitted
from one person to another by being exposed
to the theology we described above, which
the Foundation labeled SCP-2456-1.
Those affected by SCP-2456 show an affinity
towards astrology, astronomy, and pseudoscience
in general, as well as an increased proficiency
in speaking foreign languages.
There’s also prolonged episodes of psychosis,
paranoia, and Dissociative Identity Disorder,
as well as a high attention span for geometrical
shapes, patterns, and sequences involving,
you guessed it, the number five.
Usually, the SCP-2456 parasite will remain
dormant for a period of time, but once activated
by several stress triggers, the subject afflicted
with the anomaly will undergo a mind-altering
revelation, falling asleep for a period of
three to four days, experiencing vivid, cryptic
dreams involving religious prophets and figures
from various theologies being executed one
by one with a sword, and celestial bodies
“dancing” in the sky.
After this long rest, the subject will begin
preaching the -1 religion to others, causing
the parasite to transmit from one person to
another, bringing more and more followers
to its cause.
And after that, the cycle will repeat.
More followers are attracted, more begin preaching,
and before you can realize, SCP-2456 has affected
a large group of the Foundation.
With such an easily transmissible anomaly,
it's a wonder the world hadn’t been taken
over by SCP-2456 a long time ago, but when
you consider that Fifthism is already an established
belief system, maybe, in a way, it already
has.
Believers in the religion that those affected
by SCP-2456 preach are incredibly violent
and aggressive, with their strong feelings
growing more and more with every new iteration
of the religion over time.
Believers usually seek out those who haven’t
been affected by SCP-2456, and attempt to
spread the religion, and if they refuse, murder
them.
But the Foundation’s research has shown
that no individual that has been affected
by SCP-2456 has ever been successful in infecting
more than 5% of the existing human population.
Chalk it up to luck, because Foundation simulations
have indicated that a CK-Class End of the
World scenario would occur if SCP-2456 infection
rates ever exceed over 7%.
If you can’t tell, that’s pretty bad.
Not only that, but the Foundation discovered
that as the religion evolves over time, it
creates a minor reality-warping effect, and
if left unchecked, can fracture the integrity
of space and time at a high enough level.
Thankfully, the Foundation has one way to
combat SCP-2456.
During the period of time directly after an
individual wakes up from their prophetic sleep,
treating them with high-class amnestics has
been discovered to completely rid the individual
of the SCP-2456 parasite, bringing them back
to their senses.
But still, due to the memetic nature and the
high number of suspected infected individuals,
the Foundation has found that complete containment
of SCP-2456 is not physically possible, at
least with the organization’s current technology
level.
Still, that isn’t stopping researchers from
working tirelessly, trying to develop methods
of neutralizing all instances of the parasite
in the wild, taking the fight to the internet,
and making sure that their web-crawlers can
quickly scan for keywords related to SCP-2456
on websites and social media databases.
If they’re found, the Foundation can quickly
trace posts to whoever wrote them, and bring
them to a secure facility for further research.
It’s never clean work having to abduct civilians
from their homes, but in this case, given
how dangerous SCP-2456 can be if left unchecked,
it might be justified.
But how has the religion that SCP-2456 instills
in its victims, SCP-2456-1, evolved over the
years?
The manuscripts that the Foundation uncovered
inside the Serpent’s Hand hideaway detailed
six variations of the theology over time.
Let’s take a look at them.
The first variation dates all the way back
to 1837.
A religion by the name of the “God Worshiping
Society”, which was a fusion of Confucianism
and Catholicism that cropped up in China at
the time, spread by Hong Xiuquan, a Chinese
revolutionary who led the Taiping army in
rebellion against the Qing dynasty.
The stress of having to deal with the political
instability of the era resulted in SCP-2456
triggering inside Xiuquan’s mind, and causing
him to preach his variation of the -1 religion
to his followers.
This furthered the strength of the Taiping
army, allowing them to march through nearly
every province of China in retaliation until
they achieved their goal.
Some accounts of Xiuquan’s followers recount
them transforming into piles of geological
matter, which the Foundation found DNA evidence
bonded to sediment in pockets of igneous rock
in the area.
Undoubtedly a result of SCP-2456’s reality
warping side-effects.
The second variation was found in ancient
Egypt, under the name of the Cult of Aten.
The progenitor of this variation is unknown,
due to how far back it dates, but the person
who imposed the will of the Cult of Aten the
most was the then-Pharaoh, Akhenaten of Amarna,
who used his power as head of state to condemn
worship of all Egyptian deities other than
Aten.
The Cult of Aten’s reign over Egypt resulted
in several reality altering properties, including
strange behavior of celestial bodies, feelings
of stretched out, unending days, and the refusal
of the sun to set for five days, which resulted
in a drought along the bank of the nile.
Egyptian star charts from this time display
star systems, constellations, and nebulae
that do not exist, or are depicted incorrectly.
The most prominent of these changes include
the inclusion of a planet named “Nbu”,
which is described as half of the size of
Venus, that would pulsate with light in five
second intervals.
There’s that number again.
The third variation jumps to the time of the
Aztecs, and while little is known about its
origins, its impact on Aztec society was enormous.
The Aztec deity Tonatiuh was said to be the
fifth sun that set in the sky.
The Aztecs frequently made sacrifices to Tonatiuh,
and the worship of the entity caused a reality
warping effect throughout the empire.
The sun and the moon were eclipsed by unknown
celestial objects consistently for weeks.
Bodies from past sacrifices would reanimate
and attack civilians, reaching into their
throats and pulling out their hearts.
The coasts of the empire suffered from glowing
red poisons, which killed off fish and caused
tissue necrosis in humans, as well as forming
large blood clots in the lungs.
The fourth variation, the Cult of the Supreme
Being, was a short-lived religion perpetrated
by French philosopher Augustin Robespierre
during the time of the French Revolution.
Its small longevity meant that the religion
didn’t garner enough followers to cause
intense reality-warping effects, but some
anomalous characteristics were still prevalent,
such as reports of incorporeal manifestations
in the streets of Paris, dimensional shifts
in salons and smoking parlors around the city,
and the increased brutality and ruthlessness
of the revolutionaries, who imposed a large
daily quota of executions.
The fifth variation is entirely unknown.
Most likely to do with the number’s significance
to the Fifthist belief system, attempts to
access the SCP Foundation files on the fifth
incarnation of SCP-2456-1’s belief system
are met with failure, as the files data is
corrupted.
This, however, raises a new question.
Maybe this unknown religion is still one that’s
active today.
Maybe the fifth variation of SCP-2456-1 is
Fifthism itself, having evolved as a variation
of SCP-2456 over the years.
That would add a whole new level of danger
to Fifthism, as if it got out of hand, the
reality warping effects of being a SCP-2456
based theology would cause destruction to
the fabric of reality itself.
The sixth variation is similar to the fifth,
with its files being similarly corrupted in
the Foundation’s databases and all information
on it being entirely unknown, save for a single
readable sentence which states that the main
perpetrator, the prophet of this sixth variation
of SCP-2456-1, is still at large today, remaining
a threat to the world.
Knowing that this virus can affect large swathes
of the population, as it did in the Aztec
and Egyptian empires, the Foundation remains
extremely cautious of SCP-2456, especially
with the added risk of Fifthism being prevalent
in the anomalous world, and the unknown sixth
religion still at large.
Also discovered inside the Serpent’s Hand
warehouse were several manuscripts from the
various religions that SCP-2456 influenced.
Scriptures from the Cult of Aten, letters
written by Robespierre in his journal, and
even a text from the Taiping revolution, labeled
the Wisdoms of the Heavenly King.
But what did they say?
The text sourced from China described the
story of a Prophet, who wanted to bring great
knowledge to the people beneath him.
And so, as the text describes, he followed
the smoke, a Fifthist metaphor for reaching
enlightenment.
He did so by studying alongside a mentor for
five months, and on the fifth day of the fifth
month, he had achieved enlightenment, and
knew he had a great mission to complete.
He roused his subjects, rallying the people
who lived in ash and filth to war, attacking
with the power of the sun on their side.
Those who faced the Prophet ran, but the ones
who were left understood.
On the Fifth day, they turned into tar, sand,
and salt, and the Prophet remained victorious.
Sound familiar?
It’s an abridged retelling of Hong Xiuquan’s
revolution.
The rest of the text describes a parable of
a master and a student philosophizing about
the stars, with a particular poem that stands
out.
It reads:
Five spokes of a broken star
Five elements that forever spar
Five senses to evoke the mind
Five pieces slowly unwind.
A Black Moon, howling, is a vision unworthy
of one's sight.
A hymn sourced from the Cult of Aten also
makes references to the number five, and specifically
makes mention of the “Black Moon”.
If you’re familiar with the SCP Foundation’s
inner circle, the Overseer Council, then you
know that they frequently use the phrase “Does
the Black Moon Howl?”
as a security measure to access top-secret,
confidential documents.
Its true meaning, however, remains shrouded
in mystery.
But here, you see it connected to SCP-2456.
It can’t be a coincidence.
Robespierre’s diary describes an account
of the French revolution, detailing Robespierre’s
descent into madness that led to the creation
of the short-lived Cult of the Supreme Being.
The revolution descends into brutality, and
as Robespierre describes, “the streets run
pink with blood and agony” as the Cult revels
in the bloodshed and ruthlessness.
All of this points to a compelling mystery
about the true nature of SCP-2456, especially
with the connection to the commonly used symbol
of the Black Moon in the SCP Foundation.
And all of this came to a head on December
21st, 2016, when an unidentifiable audio file
was sent to a Foundation Researcher that alerted
the server's firewalls.
The audio file was traced as originating from
a cubicle that had been vacant for six years,
with hardware that had been short-circuited
and badly corroded.
A portion of the audio file was recovered
from the damaged terminal, and the Foundation
quickly began to transcribe it.
It was the voice of an unknown Foundation
employee, who detailed that he had been working
with the organization for two decades, and
that while he had seen horrible things in
the past, as he was recording this message,
he was more terrified than ever before.
He was assigned to research SCP-2456, cataloging
all the past occurrences of the various religions
that had cropped up as a result of the parasite
over the years.
He had experience in memetics, but the danger
of researching SCP-2456 was proving difficult
to contend with.
Members of the research team were succumbing
to SCP-2456, but not only that, they were
disappearing too.
After one personnel was admitted to an infirmary,
the speaker recounted that he was never able
to find them again.
The audio continued to play, and the speaker
explained that SCP-2456 also carries a potent
anti-meme, an idea that causes dramatic reality
shifts, often characterized by something being
imperceptible and unrecognizable to the human
brain.
Whenever information about a SCP-2456 religion
is read or written about, the anti-meme will
enter the subject and slowly erase them from
existence, alongside all records and knowledge
of the subject.
Sometimes, however, corpses and names remain.
The speaker detailed how he witnessed his
peers slowly disappear.
As the file goes on, he descends into typical
fifthist ranting.
Speaking about fives, following the smoke,
and a dream, but he leaves a terrifying message:
The Foundation is old, but the world is older.
Maybe the Serpent’s Hand, with their manuscripts
and research on SCP-2456 were attempting to
keep the forces of the Fifth King, a mysterious
deity the man mentions, at bay.
Now, inside the hands of the Foundation, these
documents will never be destroyed.
They will continue to be read, and continue
to linger in reality.
The speaker signs off, ranting more about
the Star Signals incident, and the Fifthist
Dream that permeates the shadows of all reality.
As the speaker states, “Once history is
forgotten, it is of course doomed to repeat
itself.
And the sixth cycle will forever more echo.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Broken God
- Ouroboros Cycle” and “Children of SCP-001
The Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
for more anomalous religions and their bizarre
followers from SCP Explained!